hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen zu einem weiteren minecraft
video ihr seht es wahrscheinlich schon
im titel eigene blendete und zwar
spielen wir heute die erste minecraft
version das ist nämlich die version die
man im launcher sieht und das ist der
sohn als ard was ich habe ein foto von
gemacht das ist version ort unterstrich
alpha ard 13 22 11 also hier seht ihr es
nochmal eingeblendet das ist die version
die ich im launcher ausgewählt habe fakt
ist ich hab mir noch zwei prozent akku
hier können wir quasi herum noch auch
kummer ich kann a
ich kann das wusste ich gar nicht dass
das geht ich dachte ich kann ich das ja
stark luca 20 jahre alt denn der gerade
mein kraft hinter der ersten version
es gibt zwei verschiedene blöcke wir
haben die möglichkeit blöcke zu setzen
und können somit auch was zum ich bin
gerade in einem blog drin schaut euch
das an ich bin in einem blog drin alter
was was zum zick kann ich irgendwie
gibt's ein inventar enters bay ich kann
nur hoffen und das sieht aus wie ein
penis das leitende funktioniert auf
jeden fall auch super hier also wir
sehen desto näher ich da hingehe desto
heller wird einfach aber wenn ich weiter
weg den wir jetzt automatisch irgendwie
dunkler und jetzt ist einfach komplett
schwarz keine sorge dass es nicht das
einzige was wir in diesem video machen
werden sondern ich habe auch noch eine
zweite minecraft version vorbereitet und
zweigen sondern die erste beta will ok
das ist dann die map in der wir gerade
drin waren
da sehen sie das loch aussehen mich
gerade rausgefallen bin ich falle immer
weiter und ja okay also es ist jetzt
nicht so als hätte ich heute noch was
anderes zu tun ich habe auf jeden fall
noch eine zweite minecraft personen
vorbereitet und zwar die erste
beta-version herausgekommen ist dann
kann man
ein bisschen mehr machen da gibt es ein
menü das spielen wir gleich mal
allerdings dann höre ich dann endlich
mal auf die aus dieser chance ihr
wegzufallen ich meinen fall ich
wenigstens irgendwo hin bekommt sofort
fand ich einfach nur unter sich hier
kann meine damen herren bei minecraft
beta 1.0 das sehen wir hier oben auch
schon so toll eingeblendet wir kriegen
jetzt einfach mal auf singleplayer
starten hier eine neue welt und sehen
schon building das dauert wieder zehn
jahre sind wir auch schon in der ersten
richtigen minecraft welt angelangt hier
rum ich kann immer noch nicht aber ich
kann's liegen
dies müssen wir laufen wir herum bauen
ein bisschen die bäume ab so dass wir
nämlich aber baum getötet und gnade den
starken gefährt qualität für frauen
gefälschte quadrate wir nehmen das holz
packen es hier ein machen uns wurden
place packen die hier hin und machen uns
eine workbench und dann da vorne machen
wir erstmal einen knicks hallo sonst
kann ich eigentlich das wär's ja wenn
ich jetzt und es waren einfach für so
richtig entspannte zeit und es gab
einfach nicht mal essens balken und man
musste sich aber nichts wirklich
gedanken machen ich kann mir jetzt
einfach hier zacken passt nichts zu
holen kann mir jetzt hier schön schwert
machen mit dem ich gleich die leute
bekämpfen machen wir jetzt noch eine
hohe so dass ich auf jeden fall
peaches anstatt kriegerin paar sekunden
später okay ich habe die linke ich habe
ich habe keine von ich habe ich habe
keine hand an der tastatur läuft gerade
aus das war nämlich auch so ein fehler
den sinn der beta irgendwie immer gab da
war es halt zu ihm okay du hast mein
gott ich bin im wasser und krebs kann
offene workbench zu interessiert uns
nicht du läufst jetzt erstmal weiter
geradeaus
das war richtig dass ich hätte so bock
ein let's play the line card ein schaf
stirb du trägst wie keiner mag ich das
wäre das einzige spiel was es derzeit
auf dem markt gibt also minecraft beta
erste version wäre das einzige spiel wo
ich wirklich ein letzte play for machen
würde wo ich sagen würde okay das will
ich nicht das ist wirklich das einzige
spielen teure münchen das wundert diese
guten alten zeiten es gab nicht tausende
sachen wie man enorm erfolgreich werden
konnte und wie man toll kämpfen kann
oder so sondern ist es einfach mal läuft
noch in höhlen und fürchtet sich richtig
weil man weiß ob kate auch wenn ich die
beste rüstung habe kann ich im körper
trotzdem töten mittlerweile kann man
alle verzaubert so dass man das macht
für mich den sinn vom spiel kaputt
mannschaft soll sie bleiben
das wird wieder so ein video wo ich
irgendwie neue das spiel hätte da holt
man sich erst mal gut luca das hast du
toll gemacht man kann halt auch nicht
sprinten das ist halt auch so eine sache
aber ich bin jetzt hier als wenn man das
nicht schafft bis zum weg bricht
erhalten scheiß weg hin
ich hatte sand und keine erde
ich bin bei der kohle angekommen baut
die jetzt klappt sind dass ich mir
gleich fakten machen kann ja keine
ahnung also thema das video soll
eigentlich nicht sein dass sich
überlegen was hetze oder irgendwie euch
frage ob ich jetzt machen soll sondern
ich habe mich einfach mal dafür
interessiert was die erste version ist
die bei minecraft im launcher angezeigt
wird und das ist halt die erste version
die wir zumindest die erste betaversion
die erste alphaversion war dieser
version wo wir runter gefallen sind
es ist jetzt nicht so als hätte ich
heute noch was anderes zu tun ich habe
gerade aus irgendeiner richtung einen
bösen zombie gehört und ich weiß
allerdings gerade nicht da ist
die stay away von mir kennen der 2 wisst
ihr das war noch ein spiel wo ich sogar
gut drin war mache ich mir hier schon
ein bisschen fackel die ich mir hier
schon hin setzte dann pack ich nicht
faktisch challenges libro im training
felix news.de ich bin jetzt total das
hab ich grad extra gemacht
an dieser stelle bendig das video meine
damen und herren ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen ich wollte nicht einfach mal so
die älteste minecraft version anschauen
aber jetzt habe ich gerade richtig bock
auf den letztlich in einem live stream
oder dass ich irgendwie immer mal am
wochenende eine halbe stunde uncut
minecraft hochladen oder irgendwie keine
ahnung in der beta-version ich weiß ihr
habt ihr lust drauf band mal den daumen
nach oben button und bei rund zehn
millionen likes mach ich das oder so als
die bessere ideen habt schreibt in die
kommentare ich habe keine ahnung also
deswegen